hey guys how's it going I'm Justine
welcome to IJ likes basically a show
where I talk about things I like simple
as that
first up this may be my most new
favorite video that's ever been posted
on the internet because trust me I know
how difficult it is to do one of these
types of projects this is a music video
for tuna melt by a track and Tommy trash
I'm I'm speechless there are no words to
explain this video there may be no words
my friends there are dance moves
so next up I think every one of you guys
have tweeted me this video it's dog
wants a puppy or gets a kitty what the
hell is it called this dog wants a kitty
kittens oh that's it that's
that's the hermit crabs oh come on come
on you've probably seen the talking dog
video before with this one it's just
it's so cute I'm a sucker for freaking
any cute animal especially a cute animal
with a human voice homie what's going on
in the pet store yep saw the turtles oh
come on
oh
what was that
understand how windy it is right now in
L.A you can you hear that
gaming and Technology oh my gosh wait
where's it at hold on a second I keep
leaving you guys I just got the new
Nintendo DS XL because I've been playing
Luigi's Mansion Dark Moon on my small DS
and I started getting headaches and
migraines and I'm like what's wrong with
me too much coffee no too much little
tiny DS trying to play Luigi's Mansion
in more gaming news the Call of Duty
Uprising DLC came out yesterday so if
you haven't played well you either have
a PlayStation or a PC because it just
came out on Xbox so if you have a season
pass you get it for free there's four
new multiplayer maps and new zombie mob
of the dead and it's really fun my
favorite map has to be Studio it's a
remake of firing range from the original
Black Ops and it looks just
looks like this this is me playing it
destroyed your equipment
can't confirm
oh my God please
oh that's one of those
pick it up we're winning this fight
all the thank you to everyone who
watched the Call of Duty Championship
last weekend we had some of the world's
best Call of Duty players here in La
competing for a million dollars well
first place wins 400 000 not a million
because that's just insane so congrats
to for Rico impact who came in first
place and envious who came in second and
it was so fun meeting all of you guys so
thanks everybody watched um I think
that's really all I have to say I'm
gonna skip the style and Beauty segment
because the last video that I posted is
enough style and Beauty I think that
anybody can ever handle
foreign
feel free to watch that if you haven't
already make sure you like this video
and don't forget to subscribe and be
sure to check out all of the videos and
everything else that I talked about
links in description to what I feel like
when I get to the end of the video I
just go on autopilot I'm just gonna go
bye
it's been like this the whole time
really why didn't any of you guys tell
me